well I don't know Debbie Reynolds is
often described as the girl next door
which means obviously I grew up in the
wrong neighborhood because where I was
the girl nice to look like Ringo Starr
miss Debbie Reynolds
nominees for Best Documentary Feature
are live my own Alison Paul do you babe
Robert Frost a lover's quarrel with the
world Robert Hughes and the Yanks are
coming marshal plum the winner is the
winner is
Robert Frost
on behalf of Charlotte we're in and
everyone else who made this picture
please and I'm speechless most important
it's yet another honor for our star
Robert Frost
those nominated for Best Documentary
store short subjects are Shagga by Simon
shiverin the five cities of June by
George Stevens Jr the spirit of America
by Algenol G Walker 30 million letters
Edgar and C to live again Mel London the
envelope please
the winner is sugar Simon
excepting for Simon chipperoni Joseph
Auerbach
but we should play him and all the other
thank you very much the Recon